[woman 1] Why does it have to be
the one person that I did everything with?
He would have given anything
to protect her.
[woman 2] Everyone was like,
"Paul, don't drive,"
and Paul would snap back and be like,
"Well, this is my ******* boat."
He was out-of-his-mind drunk.
Do y'all know Alex Murdaugh?
That's his son.
I heard a scream, and then a bang.
- [operator] 911, where is your emergency?
- [man 1] What bridge is this?
And then that's when we all
started screaming for Mallory.
[woman screams] Mallory!
Where the **** is Mallory?!
[man 2] Alex wasn't worried
about finding Mallory.
[man 3] He wanted to make sure that...
lips were sealed.
They were more worried about a cover-up.
[reporter 1] Five made it ashore alive.
Mallory Beach did not.
[reporter 2] Paul had been
receiving threats from strangers.
He was scared.
[man 4] Speculation is runnin' wild.
[man 5] For over a century,
the Murdaughs were law and order
here in the 14th circuit.
The family was under
increasing amount of stress.
[operator] Hampton County 911,
what's your emergency?
[man 6] My wife and child
have been shot badly.
It didn't seem real at the time.
[woman 3] The double homicides
of Maggie and Paul changed everything.
Think this may very well be related
to the death of Mallory Beach.
What was the motivation
other than revenge?
[man 7] There are facts that don't add up,
and bodies tied to this family.
[dramatic music playing]
The Murdaughs would
just make someone disappear.
[woman 4] There were so many rumors
that Buster and Stephen
were intimate together.
[man 8] Stephen's death is now intertwined
with the Murdaughs.
[woman 5] Gloria had found drugs
under Alex's bed.
She knew too much.
[woman 4] Moselle.
This, like, massive playground.
The way Paul told it, it was
for drugs and strippers and everything.
You can't believe
everything Paul says neither.
[woman 4] They were okay with us drinking.
They'd always get us alcohol.
You drink like that to escape.
This is the fall of a dynasty.
It was a fall from grace.
[woman 4] I do believe that Alex Murdaugh
would kill Paul and Maggie.
There you are, scared for your life.
And it's either do or die.